Here we go. We are live with another
amazing
This time
I cannot say a forsaking my father's
religion is story. We don't have an
ex-Muslim to share his testimony, but we
have a very relevant topic to the day to
the time that we're living in.
Brother Raymond, thank you so very much
for accepting my invitation. Um
I want to tell my audience I have
learned a whole lot more about Islam
after I converted to Christianity.
I was born to this religion. I was
I was taught the Sharia. I went to the
mosque. The Shias told me this and that.
I learned a whole lot from them. But
then
at 21, almost 22 years old, I converted
to Christianity and then I start I
started studying Islam.
And in a closed country such as Iran it
was very hard to get access to
books, internet, and things of that
nature. And then I came across your um
books, your articles, especially your
website. I have been learning a whole
lot.
You have done several podcasts with very
famous YouTubers, influencers, and all
that. And
I have wrote several articles. Every
time I watch one of your podcast, I
write several articles. For example,
about the myth of modest Islam or
reformation of Islam or um
everything pretty much you talk about I
have I've written articles on it. And I
just want to say thank you so very much
for giving your knowledge, giving your
background, giving your whatever you are
studying, giving it out and putting it
out to the world. You're you're
benefiting us and I'm so grateful for
that.
Today we're here to talk about your
latest book, the two the two swords of
Christ, which I'm so excited to hear.
I'll ask you and I comment in on on a
lot of things because the version of
Christianity in in Iran is very
different than the version of
Christianity that is in the West.
Out there we know who is our enemy.
And we don't compromise with them. We
don't invite them to our home churches
to the underground movement. But here is
different brother and you have wrote a
lot about it. So
please introduce yourself to the
audience. Tell us your latest book and
I cannot wait to hear.
Well, thank you very much Muhammad and
and thank you for that excellent
introduction. And I'm frankly I'm
honored to hear what you said. Um I'm
always
you know, very very happy to hear when
people tell me that my work has been
beneficial to them. That's the whole
point in the end. So thank you for that
and um
Yeah, I'm my introduction
to to your audience
Raymond Ibrahim
I was born here in the United States. My
family's Coptic Christians from Egypt,
which is the native inhabitants of
Egypt, the pre-Islamic Egyptian
Christians who converted in the 1st
century. Um so long long history with
Islam.
We know what it means to live under
Islam and with Islam and etc. etc.
So I was but I I was born and raised
here, but I kind of like understood
everything back then due to my family
and I grew up bilingual speaking Arabic
of a sort anyway, the Egyptian dialect.
And later on I am I enlarged it to speak
the more formal standard Arabic. Um and
yeah, I've been so based on my
background like yours because we are
from the region. Obviously our interest
is innate. It's just part of who we are.
Um but also growing here I also I
decided to actually study it formally. I
was a major a history major. And before
long my historical studies were
basically uh
centered around Islam and Christianity
because being a Christian whose
people are surrounded by Muslims, I
naturally had an an interest in that
nexus, you know, between Islam and and
Christendom. So really going all the way
back to my college days, my master's
thesis was about that. It was about the
first battle between Christians and
Muslims.
And since then
you know, I've been very very much
interested in still in all that sort of
thing. And you know, I mean so so really
this has been my daytime job, the Islam
issue. And I write a lot especially
about the persecution of Christians.
And mostly lately I've been writing a
lot about history. So I'm going back to
my my initial professional academic
interest, history. And
which leads us of course to the book
we're going to be talking about, which
is the two swords of Christ.
I finally got my author's copies. Here
it is.
And it's it's a pretty long one. I went
overboard in this one. So this one the
subtitle is five centuries of war
between Islam and the warrior monks of
Christendom.
And yeah, you know, what you just said
about the kind of Christianity that you
know, is in is in the East. Actually the
kind of Christianity is that proliferate
anywhere are very different from the
West.
Um and I think that's and one of the
reasons is why I wanted to write this
book. I mean, as usual these ideas come
to me. It's just innate interest. I like
history. But the lesson of course is to
show modern day Western Christians
that you don't have to be a doormat. In
fact, you're not supposed to be a
doormat. Um one of the themes that I
sort of elaborate a little bit in the
book that I think is very important is
when you talk about Jesus' words, you
know,
I mean it's all encapsulated in one
verse where he really says there's
actually a lot of verses, but one that
just comes to my mind right now, which I
rarely talk about,
is basically you know, be as harmless as
doves and wise as serpents. And it just
seems to me like Western Christians are
really good at the first part,
being harmless as doves, but they are
not at all wise as serpents. You know,
what does that latter part mean, being
wise as a serpent? Uh
It means don't be naive. Don't be
gullible. Don't be an idiot. Don't just
be kind of like my job as a Christian is
to always just you know, give you the
benefit of the doubt and have you walk
all over me and and you know, and I say
oh well, that's that's my job. I'm a
doormat. Um and again and the other
theme, in fact, the title of the book,
the two swords of Christ. This is in
fact a reference to another saying of
Jesus where basically it's in Luke.
And he tells his disciples sell your
cloak and buy a sword. And they say look
Lord, here are two swords. And he says
that is enough. Now here's a perfect
example of how modern day Christians,
what does that mean to them? It means
nothing. They'll tell you it's just it's
just symbolic. It's allegory. It's just
you know, it's just Jesus
it's just Jesus saying nothing really.
But he's saying something. I mean he
ordered them to go buy a sword. And they
looked around and they said well, here's
two. And he said it's enough. So one of
the modern day interpretations is that
when he says it's enough, he's basically
saying like shut up. That's enough out
of you. Don't you understand? I'm not
talking about two swords. I'm talking
metaphorically. In which case well, why
is he telling them to sell their you
know, I mean it gets confusing if that's
what he's saying. So to pre-modern
Christians
it actually had a different meaning.
What he was saying according to them and
it comes out a lot in the book, which is
like titled the book, the two swords
as you can see in the title, the two
swords of Christ. The reason
that he said that according to the early
theologians was that there's two kinds
of warfare that we as Christians must
confront. And one is one is the kind
that we're we're familiar with,
spiritual warfare. Okay? So you need the
spiritual sword. But then there's the
material secular warfare and you need
the material secular sword. So you know,
corporeal, incorporeal, spiritual,
secular, material, non-material.
And
and the thing is, you know, like if you
don't go with that interpret it's easy
to reject that interpretation today and
say no, that's violence. We can't do
that.
But the fact is and I quote a lot of
people in the book you know, we're
talking about the Crusader era.
If Christians did not believe that,
Christianity would have died. Honestly.
And I don't know if that's what Jesus
wanted. Because if Christians did not
defend themselves, if they would if they
turned the other cheek and said we're
going to be doormats, we're just going
to we'll never take up arms, we'll never
defend, we'll never stand up for the
right right cause, we'll never engage in
just war. It would have ended. Because
and not not even I mean Islam of course
was one of the main surrounding force
that was engulfing and swallowing up
most of Christendom historically. But
all the other forces too, pagan forces,
you know. So the idea that modern day
Christians that they have which is that
I can never ever ever engage in any kind
of violence is just it's not really
Christian. It was not under
Early Christians did not get that. And
the and the pivotal point is just war.
Okay? So yes, you are not supposed to go
and attack people to plunder them and
kill them and enslave them and take
their possessions. Okay?
The way Islam does. Yeah, by Jihad.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly, Jihad. You're
not supposed to do that. But if they're
coming to you and they're doing that to
innocent women and children, you're
supposed to fight them back. And and
this goes all the way back to St.
Augustine, which is ironic because
Western Christians including Protestants
love to claim St. Augustine, who of
course is Catholic, because a lot of
what he says resonates with the modern
era. But he's actually also the chief
articular articulator of just war. So he
was on board with warfare. And
he would have been on war on board with
warfare in the Crusades. Okay? So that's
that's in some the general idea of the
um I think there is a
I'm going to just
put a comment in here. I think there is
a point if you're sharing the gospel and
you're personally getting attacked for
the sake of the gospel, you say I'm
turning the cheek. But if somebody is
attacking my wife for no reason
or my children that they cannot defend
themselves and I am the father that been
assigned to this family to defend them
and I say I'm turning the other cheek."
I believe there is no love in that. Abs-
Love defends. That's a part of the
gospel. Absolutely. Your love defends
the people that are vulnerable, your
wife, your family, your children.
But if say if say I'm out there
I'm sharing the gospel with a Muslim,
which we do in our ministry. We are out
there, we're sharing the gospel, and
then um
I get I get attacked as a reason of
sharing the gospel. I'm I might defend
or run away, but it doesn't mean I'm
going to beat them up.
Right.
I think that's uh the confusing part in
the Western world that turning the other
cheek means as a nation also
Yeah. turn the other cheek, which is
absolutely, if you know any Bible,
Romans 13 or or any of the government
has been given to defend, Right. to
protect. Right. I mean, how you're going
to deal with uh
Romans are you going to deal with that?
That uh four? How are you going to deal
with that? That it's been It's their
assignment by God, and they have a
sword. They carried the sword not in
vain. How are you going to
But I think um it gets um
mixed with other things, and then this
being a doormat or being nice or
something like it becomes a virtue in
the church or in the body of the Christ
that means defending yourself or others
it's um not been commanded by Jesus.
No, you're absolutely right.
And your point about it's become
virtuous, you know, it's also I I call
it, you know, here's the thing, you
know, to be what we're talking about,
defending the innocent and the and the
poor and the weak against unprovoked
violence,
um it's easy to not do that. You see
what I'm saying? So, it's easy for me to
say, "No, no, I'm not going to fight
back. I'm not going to defend them." And
then I'm going to pat myself and say I'm
a good Christian.
Okay? So, a lot of I think I think this
idea of being a doormat is um sort of uh
it's so popular because of cowardice.
It's a lot of people don't want to take
It's hard to confront. It's hard to be
confrontational and objectionable and
you know, fighting back. Nobody That's
not easy. So, it's So, a lot of these
people I think who um who don't do it,
they claim they're not doing it because
they're pious, when in fact they're just
cowards. Okay? Um but your your other
points, of course, you know, we need to
completely elaborate on them. They're
all right. And the idea, of course, you
know, so the just war theory.
Think about it. What do they This This
isn't me. What do the theologians, like
including St. Augustine, what does he
cite? He talks about how, for example,
the Roman Centurion goes to Jesus uh to
to heal his servant.
And uh Jesus heals him. And then and he
and he has nothing but praise for the
Roman Centurion. I haven't found a man
of such faith, etc., right? Now,
generally, when Jesus performs a
disciple uh I'm sorry, when he performs
a miracle on someone, uh
it it it ends up and culminates with him
telling that person, "Repent." Right?
Repent of your ways. He didn't say that
to this Centurion. He didn't say, "Hey,
now it's time to quit violence." Because
as a Centurion, this man was in charge
and responsible for, you know, violence,
including killing of people. Jesus
didn't say that. He didn't say, "Now
that, you know, now you have faith, but
there's one thing missing. You go repent
and leave the military." Same thing with
the sword. He didn't tell them to sell
your sword. No, exactly.
No, but he did tell people sell your
garments and buy a sword.
So, this idea is you know, this passive
idea, which would have been so alien to
to pre-modern Christians, has become so
embedded and I think in Western society.
And I think
in it's intentional and it's from people
and elements that hate Christianity.
Okay? They are behind this. They support
this. They diffuse this message. They
convince Christians, "Your job is just
It's just an abstract idea. John 3:16,
you know, you know, God loved the world,
sent Jesus. I believe in it. That's it.
I don't have to do anything. And I
better not engage in any confrontational
violence or any objectionable
objectionable um
you know, demeanor, activity, etc., cuz
that's not Christian." And well, guess
what? That kind of belief, that kind of
behavior is precisely what the enemies
of Christianity want.
Because it means you If I was a Muslim
jihadi Yeah. and if I know I'm going to
attack you
I would first
I would take your swords away. I would
def- completely
uh strip you off your swords, your
defense, your and then ideologically, if
you were to speak about it or
um in the army term, doesn't matter
physically, spiritually, however I can
disarm you that I could be coming in and
plunder you. If I was a Muslim jihadi
and I wanted to attack the West, that's
what I would be preaching. You're a
doormat.
You're You're supposed to turn your
cheek. You're not supposed to defend. If
you defend yourself, this is not
virtuous, it's evil. Jesus is always
about love and co-exist and bringing
everybody in the house.
The
The In fact It's the ideology that the
enemy absolutely loves.
Well, what you said isn't even
hypothetical. In my book, Two Swords,
and in my other books,
I describe um instances where Muslims
and Christians debate, and that's what
the Muslims say. They try to demoralize
the Christians by saying, "Well, you're
not being good Christians cuz you're
fighting back." While they do jihad and
say it's good to do jihad. So, exactly,
people need to understand the reason you
have been disarmed and there's this
prevailing message that you can never uh
you know,
you can never be militant. Both I don't
even mean physically or lit- or
literally. I mean, figuratively and
spiritually militant.
Um it's coming from sources that hate
Christianity. This is their way of
pulling the rug underneath you and
making and defanging you and making you
absolutely neutral and passive to their
own agenda. And that's why that idea is
so popular. And and in the book it comes
again, you know, these because the book
is about these knights and Christian
fighters and how and and they actually
suffered this, you know, in the very
beginning.
Um there were Christians who were
saying, "Oh, you can't fight back." I
mean, they've that idea has been around.
Okay? But and but they would respond in
the way that I'm telling you. But and
also,
for example, they would argue, "Okay, so
violence is bad, right? So, now let's
Here's a hypothetical situation. You
There's a woman and a child, and she's
being attacked, let's say, by a jihadist
who's going to rape and kill her. Okay?"
And all you can do is either nothing or
fight back and maybe even kill him.
All right. Now, if you do nothing, well,
guess what? You've just consigned the
innocent woman and child to rape and
death. Yeah. So, how are How is that a
good deed? Someone's going to die.
Shouldn't it at least be the person
who's initiating it and you're defending
to protect the innocent? So, you see
what I'm saying? I mean, if this was
presented to Jesus, does someone
actually Instinctively, logically,
religiously, in every sense you look at
it, it makes sense that I have God has
assigned me, as specially if you're a
male or you're a father figure or you're
a pastor, to defend whoever God has
assigned to me. Like it is so logical,
it's so um
um So innate. It's such a
um
we're wired like that. You just
And it when you take that away
it is going to take a lot of uh mental
uh gymnastics and games and so many
psychological warfare to get you to the
point that you think, "Nah,
you can take my wife, God forbid, you
take my children or attack anybody that
God has assigned me, attack my church,
whatever it is, and just plunder it
because I um I've been assigned here to
be a doormat and you can walk all over
me, and I'm going to turn the other
cheek." And that's exactly where we're
at. You're right.
Yeah. And that's where we're at. You're
right. Because there's been a lot of
social engineering, especially in the
West,
to redefine Christianity along those
terms that you just described. To
convince children boys, especially when
they're born, okay, that, you know, you
you want to be a good Christian. See, it
starts off, "I want to be a good
Christian. I want to read the Bible. I
want to follow it." But then, you know,
all the you know, the message from the
the ones who supposedly understand
Christianity is you're a doormat. And
you better not do anything. You better
not Don't even try to be good because uh
that's that means you're trying to get
to heaven by works. Yeah. And it's like,
"I'm sorry, but, you know, Jesus, he
spoke mostly about action." It wasn't
you know, it
And And I And I mean, we can talk about
the book of James, all right? But most
people don't like that. So, there's
obviously uh impetus for action. And the
stuff that's nat- innate and normal,
like protecting your innocent children
and women, you know, I just can't
imagine any Christian, including Jesus,
of course, have Jesus is the one who
actually made a weapon out of cords,
created a whip, and whipped people, not
just the animals, the people, to drive
them out because he was indignant at the
cri- at the sin they were committing in
the temple. Okay? And in fact, in the
book, it talks about the the Templars
actually believed they were in the
temple, which is today Al-Aqsa Mosque.
And um they describe it They One of
their ideas was they were actually um
inspired by that scene, which is if
Jesus was whipping out these merchants,
how much more must we act to whip out
the Muslims who are actually destroying
and attacking Jerusalem and the holy
city and the holy sepulcher and all the
churches and so forth. And so, to them,
they actually described Christ as the
first knight.
Oh, wow. Yeah. Oh, wow.
Yeah. So, so the the first batch that
you're talking um about in your book is
the this the knights that they were in
the temple in Jerusalem defending
themselves and defending the temple from
the invasion of the jihadi Muslims.
Right. So, the temple was their
residence. And what had happened is this
is now the First Crusade. Let's go back
real quick and summarize it. It's 1095,
and that's when the First Crusade is
called, and the European Christians go
to the Holy Land, which is under Islamic
occupation.
It It was conquered, of course,
centuries earlier in the 7th century.
And but then it was Christian. It was It
was part of the Christian Eastern Roman
Empire, Jerusalem and all the Holy Land.
It was conquered and Islamized in the
7th century. And then, depending on the
leader and which era, you know,
sometimes it was not a lot of
persecution and pilgrims from Europe
could come, and other times it was bad.
Right before the First Crusade in 1095,
it was horrible. So, you had all the
Christians in the local in the local
regions being attacked and massacred.
European pilgrims were being attacked
and raped, and there's really horrific
stories.
And so, that gave rise to the First
Crusade, which was where we, European
Franks, the Christians, are going to go
recover the Holy Land and make sure that
these abuses are no longer, so people
can visit the Holy Land, your
Christians, without being molested and
murdered, cuz that's what was happening.
Okay?
And they were successful. By 1099, they
had
reconquered Jerusalem. But then, you
know, it's it's it's a little Christian
kingdom within an Islamic sea. It's in
the Middle East. So, the pilgrims who
would come from Europe were still being
attacked and killed before they even got
to Jerusalem. So, a group of knights, a
small group of knights who were very
pious, decided they they became monks,
and at the same time, their job, their
whole life was to protect the pilgrims
from these Islamic attacks. And they are
the knights They're They're called the
Knights of the Temple, or the Templars,
because one of the first one of the
Crusader Kings gave them the temple as
their residence.
That That was their base, their home,
their their headquarters. But But their
function was what we're talking about,
which was basically their whole function
was to protect Christians who were being
still attacked by Muslims,
so they can just simply come as
pilgrims, worship, and go back home.
Okay?
So, from the 7th century to almost 11
centuries,
we have
pretty much all of the Middle East,
as far as
Iran, Afghanistan of today, you go to
Pakistan, India, and then you come all
the way to
all of North Africa,
all of Middle East, were into
um
parts of Spain. Now, it's all conquered,
and then these Christians are trying to
go to do to to the to the Holy Land,
just doing their pilgrimage, see the
uh resurrection tomb, or the tomb of
Christ, and the resurrection sites, and
the Gethsemane Garden, and all that.
They can't. On the way, they're getting
plundered,
they're getting raped, molested, killed,
many massacred. So, imagine church sends
these people over to Jerusalem today,
and then
uh fun 50 of them, 100 of them are all
killed, or raped, or whatever. And then
So, it wasn't like that the Muslims were
uh
residing there in with harmony and peace
with other Christians and Jews, and then
these some people were
uh mistreating and abusing these
doctrines. No, they took over all of
these countries. This nation have been
Islamized, such as your country, such as
my country.
Um
the only difference I think between Iran
and and Egypt is now Egyptians speak
Arabic. Uh
Iranians fought that, and they didn't
because of the Rumi and other uh poet,
as as I recall.
But we we were all conquered. Now, we're
Islamized, and then the only religion is
Islam. And then, if if you had all of
this European pilgrims going to any of
visiting any of these countries, or
going through the Silk Road, or any of
that, they're getting plundered. And
then, finally, the church decides
decides that this is our Holy Land. And
this is the
birthplace of Christ. We need to free
it. So, they decide to take an army
there.
Exactly. Absolutely. That's a good
summary of it.
Um
And now, compare and contrast what you
just said, which is the accurate
summary, with what we're told. And what
we're told, of course, is the exact
opposite. I mean, first of all, people
want you to think that somehow Islam has
always been in the Middle East. It's
somehow organic to Iran and Egypt, for
example.
>> Absolutely not. Yes. Yeah, you know, I
mean, most people don't realize, you
know, that, for example, Christianity
was more embedded and more
you know, more permeated a country like
Egypt than than it did Europe at the
time. Or that Zoroastrianism and the
high culture of Iran was embedded. And
And you're absolutely right, you know,
I always say, you know, to the credit of
the Iranian people, they didn't
assimilate to the point that they lost
their actual language, whereas, you
know, the Coptic language is the ancient
Egyptian language. So, the the
liturgical It still exists in the
church, but people don't really speak
it. I've studied it a little, but it's
really the ancient Egyptian language
using the Greek alphabet, essentially.
And that's gone. And that's most people,
and that's why they you know, they lose
their identities and so forth, and they
get absorbed. But, you know, the idea,
of course, is that these places weren't
even Christian in the first place, and
everything was fine. And then, for some
reason, these crazy evil Europeans
decided to go there and ruin it all and
colonize Imperialistic. That's their
favorite word. This this were unprovoked
imperialist that they just wanted to
expand their kingdom.
Not because they wanted to free their
uh people, not free the lands that once
were were Christian lands, or the Holy
Lands belong to these people. Not any of
that. It was just
um unprovoked
um evil imperialist white man that just
decided to take the sword and uh kill
everybody on their way, including
children and and this and that. And
that's the story of the Crusade you
hear. But when you realize that
four centuries of absolute harassment
imperialist expansion of Islam pushed
the church to the point that they did
not have any other choice. They tried.
Negotiation didn't work. I don't know.
Uh bribe them didn't work. None of it
worked to the point that they said
we need to fight this evil. We need to
subdue it, or otherwise we will we will
not have a have Christianity. Probably
people in
England, in Frank France, in German They
would have been speaking Arabic if they
were the doormats of today.
Edward Gibbon, you know, the the the the
Renaissance time historical Well, not
Renaissance, Enlightenment historian
from England who wrote The Decline and
Fall of the Roman Empire, very popular
book. He said exactly that. And And he
wasn't a big you know, he wasn't a fan
of the Crusades. He was an Enlightenment
historian, you know, writing in 18th
century. And he actually basically says
that if it wasn't for He speaks of one
of the battles where the Christians
stopped the the Muslims in Europe, the
Battle of Tours in 732. And he says if
it wasn't for that, uh in Oxford right
now, we would be hearing the muezzin,
and we'd all be speaking Arabic. Wow.
Which now they are. Yeah. And but the
problem, and this is why I'm so focused
on history and and you know, I always
lament what I call fake history, is it's
such a powerful vehicle for what they're
trying to do, which is brainwash people.
Um like you said, you know, if you talk
I was look I was perusing through a
little book that was sent to me about
It's about the Golden Age of Islam,
etc., etc. And I'm just looking in the
intro, and it it summarizes the Crusades
in like two pages.
And oh my god, it it
Okay, the Muslims did nothing wrong.
Uh this was just about some Byzantine
emperor who's angry cuz he's losing
lands, and then the Europeans jumped on
it because they want to gain lands, and
they want to betray him. And then the
only the only stories that are shared of
Europeans are like they're cannibals.
They were eating Muslims, and they were
just And it So, and this is a PhD. It's
a well-known book. I don't even know the
title. It's somewhere here. But anyway,
you know, it's it's it's it's an
approved book. That's what you should
read. And to someone like me who knows
the actual reality, it's it's so
horrible because I know that I if I
wanted to give a summary in two pages,
okay, I mean, I'll tell you what was
happening. I'll tell you about the
persecution that prompted it. That's why
it really happened. Okay? But none of
that is there. And if you read it, it's
basically the Europeans, the Christians,
are horrible, and the Muslims are
innocent, wonderful victims, and you
know, we have a lot to learn from what
Islam did. And that is the mainstream
narrative. So, I when I went to college
and
and I studied courses specifically about
these topics, these were the books that
were given to me. And then, I made the
crazy move of actually reading primary
sources,
you know, and it was the exact opposite
story. Primary sources are the people
who lived there, Muslims and Christians.
And the Muslims are even more graphic
and more insistent that this is holy
war, this is jihad. They're contemptible
infidels, etc., etc. So,
yeah, the whole point is there's this
been subversive attack on history, so
that Christians, okay, do not understand
that actually you guys have been victims
for the longest time, and you've been
fighting for the longest time. And now
that you're finally, you know, you've
you know, the West is is been raised up,
they want you to think that that's where
you've always been, and you've been
mistreating people. There's I'll I'll
I'll give you a quick summary, and I'll
stop, but there's a book I had to
review. It's called The Crusade and
Jihad, and it's by one of these people,
you know, it's an academic, well-known
academic,
Robert Polk, I think is his name. I
think he he passed away. And I had to
review it. 1,000 page It's like almost
1,000 page the book. And the title is
Crusade and Jihad, and it claims to be a
history of the conflict, kind of like
what I do.
Okay, in this 1,000 pages, something
like the first 50 pages talk about the
Islamic conquests and attacks on Europe
that went on from 7th century to 18th
century.
50 pages, and it's just it's very
hygienic and clean, and you don't even
hear anything about atrocities or anyone
killed. It's just war. So, from 7th
century to 18th century, 11
centuries, 1,100 years of attack, it's
out of 1,000 gets 50 pages.
>> Yeah. And then the rest is the colonial
era.
Now, look at these horrible Europeans,
how they took over.
So, if you don't know any better, right,
and you read that, of course you're
going to conclude all these horrible
Europeans, horrible Christians. It is
truly a betrayal to the Western culture,
to the Western Christianity. It is a
betrayal. It is somebody intentional.
It's it's it's strategic. It's not just
It is definitely a betrayal, you're
absolutely right, but it has a purpose.
It's driven. It's driven by, you know,
forces that hate Christianity. And, you
know, instead if we can't kill
Christians, we'll make them kill
themselves by turning themselves into
little weak doormats that and everyone
walks over them and kills them. Look
what's happening in Europe with this
whole migrant crisis. You know, what
other country or like the UK, who can
Who does that? What What non-Western
country says, "Oh, everyone come in and
I'm going to stop my religion and my
culture and my customs to appease you?"
And then the government helps the
invader. Yeah, I mean, it's it's really
really warped, but the problem is people
have become so desensitized because it's
been going on for so long.
Yes. Uh empowering your enemies, not
even being neutral. You're just actually
empowering the very invaders, and then
you
>> obvious. What was that?
It's so obvious.
>> It is It is It's backward, truly
backward. Yeah.
You would thinking, okay,
regardless of the political view of
whatever nation that is,
you
the people have elected you to defend
your own people, and now you have
abandoned that task, the basic task of
defending your own people. You have
Now you're inviting and empowering
your invaders, plus
if somebody talks about what is
happening, then
from your own people, you criticize or
even prosecute, persecute your own
It is mind-boggling. Like,
uh if
>> But do you see if Islam could have ever
written a better um
uh
book or
Yeah? any any invasion uh theory, this
would be it. Yeah?
And but but you know, we what you
described, we come back to the point,
which is the only reason they get away
First of all, this phenomena that we
just described and you just kind of
underscored, um
it's only in the West. You There's no
non-Western nation where that acts that
way. There's no non- what I don't care
if it's Islamic, Buddhist, you know,
Japan, Hindu, okay, Latin American,
nobody in those countries says, "Oh, you
are outsider, come in and dictate to me
how I should live, and I I'm going to
change everything to make it comfortable
for you." That never happens. The reason
it's being explo The The reason the West
can be exploited goes back to this
doormat Christianity idea. Okay, it's on
the one hand, whichever Christians
remain in the West have bought into
this, "Oh, it's my job to just let let
people come in and do whatever they
want." And even the non-Christians, we
have to admit, people don't realize
this, even if you are a secularist or an
atheist, your culture, if you're a
Westerner, is still infused with
Christian ideas. Okay, so being a nice
guy and turning the other cheek, making
room for the outsider, that's still part
of Western culture, even if you're an
atheist. So, the reason that all that
they can do that and exploit and you
know, take advantage of Western people
and turn them into these doormats is
this assault and undermining of
Christian theology.
I mean, when you're talking, there is
like at least 50 different questions
from every point that pops up in my mind
that could get us off what we're trying
to talk in regards to for example
For example, this um
very idea of let's say
um I'm an atheist, I'm a secular person
in in the Western world or in in in
Christianity, and then you just dis
uh
deny that there's anything Christian
about the founders of the West or
anything uh
anything Everything is pretty much It is
discredited as being Christian or
biblical, but everything that it is
about freedom freedom, human rights,
respecting of others' life, actually,
nature that you don't see in any other
place, for example, in Iran,
practically all animals have been
extinct.
They have been hunted
poached because
if there is a respect, it comes from the
Bible that you respect what God has been
given to you as a steward. You're not
the owner. God This This belongs to God
of the Bible, and you're as a steward, a
manager to manage it well. And then you
say, "No, that's No, it
The founders were a bunch of deists and
and they never believed in any anything
biblical or this is just an
afterthought, and they need to get away
from it." And the more you get away from
it,
then you're going to be invaded by very
strong theology theology such as Islam
that they they don't play these type of
games of I'm here to coexist.
And if you say, "Well, Christ is the
only way to salvation," that's bigotry
now. But to them, if they say, "Allah is
the only way," "Oh, we love Islam." It's
like, how did we, brother, how
how many centuries has been this
brainwashing going, this programming has
been going that we are here in the West
that we think this is virtuous, that we
abandoning our history, our our
religion, and
for the sake of being accepted by others
or being nice to others.
Where all of this is starts?
Well, okay, so
great points. So, think about it. First
of all, it's all those atheists who
insist, you know, Western atheists who
insist, you know, there's no real
Christian background to the West, etc.
Here's one simple question. Okay, so why
did all of the principles that what, you
know, secular Western humanists uh in
you know, prize, all those principles,
why did they just happen to happen in
Christian nations and not in Islam, not
in Buddhist, not in Shinto lands, not in
Hindu lands? We always hear how advanced
Islam was in the Golden Age. Why didn't
all of these humanitarian principles
rise there? Because the bottom line is
they do come from the Bible. They do
come from Christianity. And whether
you're a Christian or not, whether you
call yourself an atheist, if you're If
you are a product of Western
civilization, you've imbibed these these
humanitarian impulses. You know, the
idea of dignifying the woman or even
monotheism, that's Christian That's
Christian. If you believe that and
you're an atheist, well, you guess what,
it comes from Christianity. Uh that's
why you believe that. The idea of you
know, it's funny because they always
attack Western European white people as
the as apparently the only people who
ever enslaved anyone, right?
And yet Yeah, of course, whites and
Europeans did enslave people, but so did
everyone else, and everyone enslaved
whites, too. But the one thing that the
whites did that the non-whites did not
do is they actually abolished slavery
around the world. And primarily England
in the 19th century is the one that made
sure slavery was basically extinct. It's
of course back now in the world, and a
lot of it is in the Islamic world, and
especially in Africa and Asia as well.
So, the my point is, you know, you can
try to hide and you can try to
dissemble, and you can try to turn
Christianity into something it's not and
say the founding the founders of the US
and whatnot were deists and they weren't
real Christians, etc. etc. But the
entire civilization of the West is
completely founded on Christianity more
than it is on anything else. More than
it is on Greco-Roman philosophy, okay,
more than it is on you know, the
Enlightenment and the Renaissance. It's
so embedded in its fabric, even though a
lot of people are trying to suppress and
deny and and excise it out, it's still
the the main thing that colors people's
worldview, including including if not
especially the people who hate it so
much, you know, these Western leftist
types who don't even understand where
all their principles come from.
And um it's very appealing to other
nations, other people group, people that
they want to
seek refuge even,
such as people like me.
Why didn't I flee to China? Yeah.
And I I was trying to get to the West as
a persecuted Christian, former Muslim.
Apostasy punishable by death in Iran.
Why didn't I Why didn't I go to, I don't
know,
let's say Vietnam or any other nation
that is out there that is
non-Christian? Because
you don't have freedom. Because where
where there's no Bible, there's no
freedom. The basis of the freedom is the
Bible that love your neighbor,
and be good Do Do unto others as you
want to be done to you. Anyway, I think
uh you and I
have carried on this conversation and
and it goes about 52 other different
directions. But I really want to get to
the two swords of Christ, the two swords
of Christ. So, we talked about the first
batch of
knights that they went to defend the
temple. And uh pretty much what Jesus
did that made a whip and God cleaned up
the temple, "This is my father's house.
Why are you making a
um mockery out of it?" And now the
knights, reading those passages, those
Christians, they're like, "Now we have
been plundered. We need to clean up the
temple." So, they go and free up the
land. So, what is the second batch that
you're talking about
in your book? So, as I mentioned the
book, the title of the two swords of
Christ is sort of a play on the verse
where Jesus talks about two swords, but
it's also about two groups. One is the
first one which you just mentioned, the
Knights of the Temple or the Templars.
And the second one are the Hospitallers
or the Knights of St. John of the
hospital. And they, when you really look
at what what their whole genesis is, are
even more telling. So, these guys start
off as they're actually older than the
Templars. They are a Christian order and
they are just dedicated to it's a
hospice. So, you know, a hospice back in
the day before hospitals, they built a
hospice in Jerusalem and they were also
attacked by the Muslims there back and
forth and they had to pay a lot of money
to the Sultan to exist. But the whole
point of the hospice was for whenever a
Christian pilgrim does come, we can help
them. We can give them a place to live,
to sleep. We can feed them. We can try
to take care of their health medical
needs, whatever. So, that's their
origin. And the verses that actuated
them are of course the ones that are
what you mentioned, which is to help
your fellow man. So, their prayer
included something, you know, to our
lords, the sick. Okay, so they are
servants of the sick. Now, you know,
the word hospital today comes from these
guys, the Hospitallers. They are the
origin, okay? And at this point they're
not militants. So, they're just, you
know, monks who are serving the sick and
needy and the travelers and the
pilgrims.
But before long, after the Templars,
they start realizing, "Okay, so, you
know, why are we helping these people?
Because by the time they come to us,
they've already been attacked and mauled
by the Muslims."
So, why don't we actually nip it in the
bud and try to and try to protect them
just like the Templars. Okay, so they
became militarized in the same fashion.
But it's very ironic that, you know, who
could think that Think about a nurse.
Like let's say a male nurse. That is the
most militant guy at the same time. But
it But you see the purpose and the
function. It's not because he's he's
just a violent man. No, he wants to help
the sick and needy. The lords are sick
and and poor. And the only way you can
do it, instead of sitting back and
saying, "All right, I'm going to wait
until you get attacked and mauled and
raped and then when you come, I'm going
to wipe your wounds."
The the way he they decided to do it is
we're going to go on the offensive and
make sure we protect you.
Battle by battle, sword by sword, fire
with fire. If they come at us, we are
going to fight them in the same exact
kind.
And you know, they I get into all the
theology and the biblical verses, the
just war and whatnot that justified both
of them. But I just find it, you know,
they're they're such they're so amazing,
especially to a modern day Christian,
because on the one hand
they're very pious. These are monks. So,
when they're not
when they're not at war, they're
actually like on their hands and knees
praying and and fasting. And okay,
that's what they're doing. And but then,
as a part of their they justified it the
war against Muslims, they justified it
as a as an aspect of love for fellow
Christians. Because why would I just let
them go get mauled and killed? You know,
I have to stand up. And if someone's
going to be get hurt, let it be the
aggressor. Because until they learn to
stop being aggressors and fighting. So,
it's very I think it's very unique and
very shocking to modern day Western
Christians to come across something like
this, because to them, I mean, again, go
back to the hospital idea. You know, a
nurse, a male nurse, he's the last
person in our mind today that we would
ever think of as being militant. Because
how can you reconcile helping people
with fighting people? But that was there
was no contradiction in those days,
because if I want they understood to
help people means I have to fight those
who are trying to kill them. Okay, and
so that's kind of an interesting the
riddle, as I call it in the book, of
these two military orders. And there
were other ones, but these are the
primary military orders.
I don't
When you start talking about this monks
and then they they
picked up their swords,
meaning their their defense the line of
defense go gone one layer in advance
that why we wait till they get injured
and then we tend to their injuries. We
how about we stop them from getting
injured in the first place? Preemptive.
brought this to my mind that the there
was an era that I think some pastors
were called black robe regiments in
America. Yeah, yeah. The very pastors
that they were preaching Sundays that,
"Hey,
this is a situation." And then those
people picked up the sword on defending
the nation.
But in in today's it's like blasphemy
pretty much if you say, "I am I'm a
clergy. I'm I'm a Christian." And then
um
even they made What was the name of the
the movie that this guy was Christian
and never wanted to pick up a gun and it
said, "I only rescue people."
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Hacksaw Ridge or
something?
>> I mean,
it's it's like that that's Christianity.
If you want to defend, you're just going
to But if you take the gun, that's not
Christianity. So, there's an interesting
idea here, you know, and and it
it helps explain what's going on. So,
the problem with modern day man,
including modern day Christians, is
they're materialists.
And what that means is
you know, and okay, a regular atheist
secular materialist, it means I just
believe in the material, I believe in
what I see, none of this spiritual mumbo
jumbo. Okay, that's that's concrete
materialism.
But I would argue that a lot of
Christians kind of adopt that same
worldview. They say, of course, we
believe in the spirit and we believe in
spirituality and afterlife. But by their
actions you will know them. And they act
like all that really matters is the
material. So, now when you take that
concept, now pre-Christians, earlier
Christians, they actually didn't. They
were not materialists. Okay, to them the
spiritual world was maybe even more real
than material world. Now, I tell you all
this to make sense of something, because
to the earlier Christians, killing
someone was not a big deal. St.
Augustine said, "People are going to die
anyway. Everyone's going to die. You're
going to die, I'm going to die. So, if
someone gets killed, you know, earlier
than when he should have because we're
stopping evil, it's not a big deal." But
today, because because life is short
anyway and then he's going to go to
judgment as you will, too. So, that was
the prevailing understanding and it
comes out in the book. But today, even
Christians, they cling on so much to the
material life, okay, that the idea of my
hurting and possibly taking away
someone's life, they think is the
greatest sin.
But it wasn't seen that way, because
ending, you know, the finite material
life, that's not the end of it from the
earlier Christian conception. That's
just the beginning.
Beginning. Okay, that's just the the
husk of flesh. Okay, and if it happens
to die now instead of 5 years from now
or 10 years, not an issue. Again, St.
Augustine is the one that really
underscored this. So, that's why I think
so many Western Christians are so, you
know, I can never hurt anyone. Because
despite themselves, they don't know it,
they're materialists. To them, the
ultimate most important thing in life is
the physical, which is the life in the
now, even though they claim to believe
in an afterlife and a spiritual life and
so forth. So, it comes out in their
worldview and actions.
Yes. Wow. Wow.
Wow. You want to take a break?
No, it is
one of it's true, because first of all,
the the your life wasn't as long as
today and you didn't have all this
luxuries that you desire if you lived in
a
I don't know, in the Roman eras or the
second, third centuries. I mean, the
Christians were dragged and thrown
before beasts. So, like
what what what good about this to desire
in a materialistic worldview? So, better
be a better be a god. Better be a
spiritual world. And now when you think
about it, wow.
It is so true. That
to desire this life is
um that's all it is and
you become materialistic as a Christian.
So,
there's a comment there's a question for
you in in the
Seth is asking, "Raymond, was Muslim
kidnapping of Christians
uh slave a motivation, Christian as
slaves a motivation for the Knights of
Templar to fight back?" Was the Muslim
kidnapping? attacking and taking
Christians on as slaves
and and sell them, of course, to slavery
or raping them or or so so many other
things. Is this was a motivation to the
Knights to fight back?
Well, well, that would be a that would
be under the umbrella motivation. In
other words, of course, the main
motivation is just protecting
Christians. Whether it's just from
normal attacks, whether it's from death,
whether it's from slavery, whether it's
from rape. So, it's essentially the main
motivation is to protect Christians
and from all the above. You know, of
course, from slavery. You know, the
Knights of St. John who outlived the
Templars and eventually became a naval
force later on from Malta and Rhodes,
a lot of their work would be to attack
Ottoman and Mamluk Muslim Muslim vessels
and basically free the galley slaves who
were Christians. Wow. You know, and they
you've seen movies like Spartacus and
the galley slaves. That was a big thing
in the Mediterranean in the 15th, 16th,
17th century and they were always
Christians who were seized and, you
know, horrific treatment, living your
life basically underneath the hull of a
boat. But they would they really
specialized and they would glory once
they, you know, they would release X
amount. And I actually in the book, I
have a picture of that, I think.
Charles V
where he's releasing a number of slaves
from North Africa. I think the number
was like 20,000. I don't know if you can
see it. Um
You see the bottom picture, he's in the
red. Yes. They're like naked and they're
running. And so he basically freed them
and So the the Muslims would capture
these Christians and then they would it
would use them as pretty much the
propeller of their boats and ships.
And then finally a king decides now we
need to free our people and goes after
them and get 20,000 of them. And uh
Nobody knows that about him. Mostly he's
laughed at now because he's kind of they
talk about anything and everything
including his weird facial structure.
You'll never hear anything noble about
him. But that was one noble act that he
did, you know? And I never heard it
until I read primary sources and I came
across it and then I found that that
picture I showed you was actually drawn
maybe two decades after it happened. So
it's rather contemporary. And they were
celebrating that an emperor was freeing
Christians from Muslims.
Wow.
And
um
I want to
little
in between the Crusades we have 1095 the
Crusades or the first Crusades
happening. And then we have six is that
632 the death of Muhammad? Uh the
self-proclaimed
What was that?
632, you're right.
>> 632. So um what happens between this 632
the
was it Omar that takes takes over and
then the uh
movement of Jihad expansion of Islam it
goes to the next level after the death
of Muhammad. And then
what happens that the Christians
for example in Syria, in Iraq, in
Lebanon of today or other places
what happened to them? Why they didn't
decide that we should have stopped and
and fight now?
Now we're 1095 that they decided to
fight the first Crusade. So why didn't
happen I don't know in 650 for example?
Okay, you have a good question. So first
of all just to give it some background
and context as as I briefly alluded when
Muhammad dies in 632, what we call the
Middle East and North Africa was
primarily Christian, overwhelmingly
Christian, more so than Europe. So if
you talked about Christendom in the 7th
century, the majority of it was in the
Middle East and Africa. That was the
more populous, the more
including theological
as far as being learned. Alexandria was
the main school the main catacomb school
for example. Um so Muhammad dies you and
you talk about Omar and so forth and you
have the great Arab conquest and before
long all that area is conquered and
under Islamic rule including Iran and
Egypt. Our countries get conquered right
away. Okay. Now believe it or not there
is resistance. So for example I know
amongst the Coptic Christians the
natives they did rise up on numerous
occasions. They were just beaten back.
You know that and you know the proximity
didn't help for either country for Iran
or for Egypt because we're so close to
you know the Islamic heartland which at
the time
the Umayyads is Damascus.
So obviously they could marshal all
sorts of power to you know quell any
sort of insurrections but they did
happen. Um the fight back the the the
actual rebuttal the the first Crusade
that was the Europeans. And so basically
so to get the perfect context. So Islam
conquers the Syria, Iran, Egypt, Iraq,
the Middle East. And then it goes all
throughout North Africa conquering
modern day nations Libya, Morocco,
Algeria, Tunisia.
And then they conquer Spain less than
one century after Muhammad's death.
Spain is now Muslim. Okay. Literally one
century after Muhammad he died 632 732
one century is the Battle of Tours the
one that I mentioned where Gibbon Edward
Gibbon said that if they won the Quran
would be preached in Oxford. And of
course it's it's preached in Oxford now
under different reasons and
circumstances.
They didn't have to win through
violence.
But
and then you you know this Jihad goes on
conquering Christian lands the
Mediterranean islands all get attacked
and conquered Eastern Rome the Byzantine
Empire is being pressured and attacked.
And even you know even
the Dark Ages which is what Europeans
or historians would call the Dark Ages
in Europe which was essentially you know
the 8th 9th centuries and it's usually
attributed to the Germanic tribes who
who caused the who overthrew Rome. Okay
that that used to be the but one
historian made a very compelling case.
His name is Henri Pirenne and he's a
19th century historian and his theory
was actually it was Islam that ushered
in the Dark Ages. Because they had
because of the way they severed Europe
because of remember Christendom was one
it was called one Christian lake the
Mediterranean. And you had all of Europe
above and in the south you had
North Africa and the east you had the
Middle East. It was one lake. So once
they cut that and they took North Africa
and the Middle East Europe was on its
own and like I told you that was the the
weaker brother the younger brother.
It was cut off from the powerful East at
the time. And um
Islamic assaults continued on it and
that is the beginning of the Dark Ages
and in in the feudal era. And people
could couldn't Christians couldn't live
in the coastal areas because that's
where all the Islamic slave raids would
come and they went up in the uphills and
the you know the feudalism begins in
that context.
And anyway so finally you fast forward
and this continues going on. The Turks
finally come and they now they they
the their Jihad goes even further. Now
they're conquering Anatolia which is
today Turkey because they conquered it.
And they're finally right in front of
Constantinople or the Byzantine region.
And and and that that time in the
sources so we're now in the 1050s. Okay.
The sources talk about tens of thousands
of Christians being slaughtered in Asia
Minor. Greeks, Armenians, Greeks,
Georgians, Syriacs and then this is also
the time where the European pilgrims are
being attacked and killed. Which is and
all of that finally causes the the
the knights of Europe essentially which
have finally become strong enough to
offer a rebuttal. They weren't strong
enough in the earlier centuries. This is
when they're
running away essentially from Islam. I
mean you have the Battle of Tours but
they're not taking the offensive. Now
they finally take the offensive go back
into the Holy Land. And it's funny
because people don't tell you this but
the the Armenians and the Syriacs and
the the Greeks who were living in the
East under Islamic rule when the
Crusaders came they basically fell on
their hands and kissed their feet and
because all they saw were these big men
with crosses
coming to fight their historical
oppressor and you know going into
churches and and being believers. And it
was just like it was to them like
salvation. And no no one will ever tell
you that. They'll they'll act like no no
it was
Catholics and Orthodox didn't get along
etc. No. The lay people actually
completely appreciated. So that's anyway
why it was such a belated response
because the Muslims were completely
overwhelming Christendom until finally
the knights you know the the the the
chivalrous order was able to respond.
And that's why it's ironic because the
first Crusade
amongst historians up until recently was
a glorious kind of um endeavor and now
it's been so pulled out of context it's
absolutely the most shameful thing. Yes.
There's a group of I'll finish it right
here but there's a group
the the the first Crusade conquest of
Jerusalem is in 1099.
In 1999 1000 years later this large
group of Germans went on a pilgrimage
to to the Holy Land from Germany wearing
shirts that said in Arabic I'm sorry
for the first Crusade.
They like
You tell me how do how does a Muslim
register that when they see that? Oh
they're like these people are absolutely
out of their mind. Like totally
absolutely out of their mind. Like then
in uh um one thing I I have two things
to say. First of all uh
the Iranian people right at this moment
47 years of oppression of Islam in Iran.
Uh the Islamic regime I'm not talking
about the historical Islam because
when when the king of Iran the monarch
prior to the Islamic revolution
uh the Ayatollahs was in charge. Yes
Iranians were Muslims but they weren't
oppressed.
There were trades and flights from
Tehran to Tel Aviv and another things.
I think they called it the South Korea
of the Middle East. But um lo and behold
the Ayatollah comes in power Sharia
becomes the law of the land. And Iranian
people now
went from a secular Islam to actually
now you have to practice. This is not
the house of war anymore. This is the
Dar al Dar al Islam the house of Islam.
Now you need to practice Islam.
And we'll force you to paradise. Why
this is important because now when the
12 days war between Israel and Iran was
happening I saw this
Raymond with my eyes. I saw this from
Iranians. They said if Israel ever gets
on the land to fight there were more
Iranians joining the supposed enemy.
But they were joining this they called
it the soldier of Moses. The Iranians
will join the soldiers of Moses to take
and remove their oppressor Islam.
Now I really it's like
where you shared about this
Constantinople situation then they the
um uh Crusaders were coming in. I felt
like that. I'm like that is so true if
if ever America attacks in order to
liberate Iran from the hand of the
Ayatollahs Iranians would be thanking
God and thanking the American soldiers
or the Israeli soldiers that coming in
to liberate them. I just I just felt it.
Like
I'm like this is so true. Maybe the
clergy and the Imam and and
whoever is in the mosque is not going to
agree with it.
Or maybe some I don't know some
Christians in inside Iran the uh
um whatever establishment that is in
Iran they would say no this this is not
the right but the people of Iran they're
going to fall on their knees and they
going to thank
the soldiers for for rescuing them out
of the oppressor the original oppressor
which Benjamin Netanyahu call it
actually the common enemy between Iran
and people and the Jews are this very
enemy.
The Ayatollahs of Tehran. And this this
actually reminds me of you know of of
the true nature of the colonial era. You
know I mentioned it to you and I I
basically said this is historians kind
of pull it out of context. They don't
talk about the long war that I described
for a thousand years of Islam's assault
on the Christian world and they just
look at the colonial era. But what but
even that is they don't tell you the
fact that a lot of the native people
were so happy that Europeans came in and
and and put an end or you know minimized
religious rule. And this includes
Muslims. Uh you know I read for let's
say in Egypt I read a lot of writings
contemporary writings during the time
under British rule and they you know
people including Muslims talk about it
as this was the greatest time because
you know we had science and technology
and progress and literacy and and
equality and
you know you're right it's people forget
it's not like a Muslim gene for everyone
to want Islam. It's the ones who
actually profit and are in power because
of Islam.
>> greatly benefit from the whole
controlling
the
I think it is the isolation. The Islam
is the master of providing isolation
because
the ideology only survives in the
vacuum. When debates happen it's just
there's so many holes in it such as
worse than the Swiss cheese that you you
just start talking about Islam it will
fall apart. You don't need to bring any
other ideology such as Christianity or
Judaism Buddhism or any just talk about
Islam show show Islam to Muslims they
realize this is not a
divine inspired anything. This is just a
man creating its own God and calls it
Allah and then being inspired by Allah
to do whatever he wanted to pleases him.
That's the bottom line of Islam but the
the Muhammad realizes this of course and
then passes passes down this to his
caliphs that we can't have debate we
can't have anybody make fun of us. We
can't have anybody that is um
um debating us or anybody that disagrees
it's mushrik is infidel just get rid of
him. You then they create this
isolation for Muslims
which creates this
really weird controlling situation to
keep them in that bondage for the
whatever uh
political reason or other reasons that
they have. So And what you explained
what you explained is very important
because it's
it's 100% true but it's also applicable
to what Western people are suffering
from right now which is called the left.
Okay the bottom line is so let's go to
what you just said Islam is Islam cannot
brook or tolerate discussion because
it's so easily exposed. This is why they
have blasphemy laws. Okay this is the
number one reason even
I I translated something a long long
time ago from Ibn Taymiyyah who
basically says that you know like yeah
actually words against Islam are worse
than war and violence because they have
the power to completely destroy it. So
that's why it's so stringent and
fanatical about what you say and any
criticism. But now if you move to the
west then you have this power that they
call the left and I hate that word
because it's not accurate but
you notice that even though the left is
supposed to be liberal and open-minded
Yeah. they are like Muslims when it
comes to debates. They don't want anyone
opening their mouths they don't want
anyone challenging them. They lie they
distort they
that's the whole that's the whole cancel
culture right? Yes. No free speech for
you.
And that also explains why a lot of
people wonder why are Muslims and
leftists in you know allied they're so
opposite. The Muslims are draconian
authoritative conservative and the
leftists are the exact opposite.
>> Supposedly they they have a theology
they have a God or something but then
the liberals the leftists they're
godless. How did they align so well? How
did they mesh in and and get together so
well? I mean one is atheistic one is
monotheistic supposedly. This is not
going but then you just go one step one
inch below the surface you're like my
God this is the exact same practices.
Mhm. And the reason is once you get past
the you know the admittedly very
different surfaces right? The one is the
left and all it believes liberalism and
one is conservative patriarchy and toxic
masculinity and whatever right? Islam
you find out really when you get beneath
all these things what's going on is it's
a battle between truth and falsehood.
Yes. Christianity is the truth and
falsehood has different faces different
anything that's not true is false and
there's a myriad countless forms of
falsehoods. So one is the left
as we call it and one is Islam. They
look
>> swallowed up permanently Islamacized and
then the rest was constantly embattled
by all these forces that were discussing
but especially the Muslim forces.
So if if if Christians had not
the knight culture had not developed as
it did precisely then Christianity would
have died.
I mean there's no doubt about it. And
and earlier historians knew this. And so
it's it's kind of ironic when you get
these today you know I'm a modern day
Christian I have nothing to suffer I I
don't worry about anything my life is
leisurely and easy but I judge and and
poo poo people because they're fighting
back. How dare you? I talk about
Christians being persecuted in the
Middle East in Nigeria and then I'll
I'll get a Western Christian telling me
something like well it doesn't matter
because you know are they saved though?
Or something to that effect or well
Jesus wins in the end so and it's kind
of like in the in the days that I were
talking about in the first crusade no
one said that. It's not because they
didn't believe or have faith. They just
thought that they were called to do
something to help their fellow brother.
Okay because they actually were cuz
that's what Christ says.
And that's what actuated them.
Wow how far have we come?
But
I want to tell you brother there is um
um in the west especially I see that um
when people are seeing the courage in
you it seems that it is in fact um
uh getting transferred to them also
impacting them too. And um
um
in the beginning I think 10 12 years ago
when I started talking about these
things people constantly would say
are you aren't you
worried about safety your safety? Aren't
you worried about speaking out? And um
it this was very confusing to me. Like
this is America, I think. Uh this is the
safest for Christians so far. And uh why
everybody is concerned about safety? And
I searched to see if Jesus anywhere
said, "I want you to go be
um
worried about your safety and your
protecting your life." But what I found
in the Bible in the words of Jesus, he
said, "If you protect your life,
you're actually losing it. And if you
lose it for my sake, you actually find
your life."
It's like there's certain verses or
certain passages, certain parts of
the Gospels or the New Testaments not
being preached. Yeah.
It is
>> That verse that you just said was always
on the lips of these knights.
Yeah.
They saw their death at war as I'm dying
for Christ.
Why? Because
didn't Jesus say, "If you do this to the
least of me, you know, you you help
people, you're doing it for me"? Well,
that's what they were doing. They were
not fighting for plunder, gain, or
wealth. They were doing it to protect
the least of Christ's brethren and
children. Yes. Okay. So, they they saw
it. And it's just it's one of the worst
thing that's happened in the modern era.
And I I'm telling you it's by design,
it's intentional. It's one of the key
ways that the enemies of Christianity
have have neutralized Christianity is by
pulling out of context the peaceful
verses and convincing Christians you
Yeah, here it is. You want to be a good
Christian, you never ever ever take up
arms. But in fact, it was always a part
of the Christian tradition. But once you
convince Christians that Oh, you can
They've convinced Christians today that
you can't even speak up. You can't be
confrontational. You can't even say
something. You have to just be a
doormat. Turn the other cheek, as they
say. Even though Jesus himself in the
one recorded instance where he was
slapped did not turn the other cheek. He
actually questioned his slapper. Okay.
So, there's obviously symbolic relevance
to much of what Jesus says about the
passive the passive verses. So, anyway,
my point is this is all by design, it's
all intentional, it's all a way to to
sabotage Christianity and weaken it from
within by having Christians essentially
commit suicide and say, "We will never
defend anything because that's the
Christian thing to do."
Yeah. Um that is not the Christian thing
to do that we defending ourselves.
That's
But I think um
I think the more um
your books are coming out, the more
people are talking about about it. I
think there is an awakening. There's
there's there's a movement. Um
uh what you see in the West that people
are
I think the Western Christians are fed
up with these things. Um
I'm not talking about Episcopalian, God
forbid, or Methodist or or the those
sects. It's just like some of them has
been um
so weakened. And then that Now you see
the uh trend of homosexuality in the
clergy or
I mean and then they're invited
>> It's all inter- the same spirit.
>> I was going to connect it when when that
happens, you have for example this
homosexual clergy, then then you have
the interfaith dialogues where they
bring in Muslims in and you're just
seeing the weirdest coalition is
happening.
But then you have this remnant of God,
the people, the knights of Christ,
whatever you want to call them, that are
seeing it. This is not what Christianity
is. Yeah.
This is not what we are called
believers.
We're called to defend Yeah. the
vulnerable, the the weak,
to take care of the sick and the widows
and the orphans, to defend our our
nations, our borders. You're It's just
um it has been a slow, but I think the
pendulum went from one side to another
and now it's coming back. And I'm hoping
by the grace of God that um
um before it's too late. I think it's
too late now for England to wake up. Um
it Germany to wake up. It's uh I have
traveled there.
This is uh I'm a former Muslim.
Um uh I come from um the IRGC
background, Iranian Revolutionary Guard
background. I've been trained by them.
And then
the there are not very many things that
intimidate that intimidate me as as as a
person, generally speaking, being in
that type of environment and then being
in the underground church of Iran uh
among believers that God knows my pastor
would get arrested every other week.
Like it it he he had a spot in the
prison. Like And and then he would come
back as to a small children. And then he
would tell us, "I I was able to share
with people there." And then then the
guards get mad and then threw me out.
And we looked at those Christians were
like, "Glory to God. I mean, what is in
this life that you should be afraid of
dying if that's your example?"
[Music]
All all to say, brother, is that um
when I traveled to Germany, when I
traveled to England, I was more afraid
than when I was in Iran or in Middle
East ministry.
The version of the version of Islam I
see, the Salafi, the Wahhabi, that type
of yellow-bearded
ugly-looking with the mark of the beast
on the on the forehead,
you you're like this even is worse than
Middle East now.
They're scrolling around on a on a
Friday. If you drink or you're not
wearing your hijab, that they're
enforcing the Islamic code. I mean, in
Germany. I mean, people don't believe
it. I was more intimidated there. And I
think to
take Europe back now, it is very very
difficult. It is going to take literal
knights I'd like you to elaborate a
little bit because you're touching on
something that I know, but you can even
speak better about it, which is
basically um
I mean, in the West often times they try
to present Iran as the absolute bogeyman
of Islam,
which I know it's not because first of
all it's Shia. And yeah, say what you
want, Shias are a little more mystical
and moderate than the Sunnis and the
Salafis especially.
Um so, you're telling me that when you
walk in the streets of Iran, it's it
doesn't look as radical as walking in
the streets of Birmingham, England,
right? Absolutely. 100%.
I have witnessed both of them in my
eyes. It's not like I need to read it
someplace. No, I know. I know.
>> When I was in Birmingham, when I was in
um
London, parts of London, I mean, I could
not believe my eyes. Like what is
happening here? I was in Germany. I'm
like, "This is gone too far."
I mean, Iranians are turning away
from Islam.
You're turning And
the Islam that is in the Europe is worse
than the Islam that we've been
practicing for the past whatever 14 so
>> Well, it's worse. Here's the thing, it's
worse, I think, because the people
bringing Muslims into Europe are
bringing the worst ones. The worst one.
That's
Even Muslim countries don't want them.
Yeah. It's It's kind of like what I hear
here in America. And now the same
thing's happening, which is, you know,
the people come from Mexico is giving us
their criminals, the people they don't
want. So, it's almost like in Europe,
the Muslims, it's not It's not There are
good moderate regions that are better
than others. Okay? But they're bringing
literally Salafis and Wahhabi types, you
know, the and jihadists.
>> Yes.
>> Those are the ones that are brought into
Europe. And this is why it's so hard to
imagine that this is all organic, that
it's not by design, that this is just
happening. No, there's a there's
something going on that's very
intentional and very destructive and
with a very ill intent.
>> very diabolical that is going on that is
empowering, bringing these people. And
then then then there there is so many
uh nonprofits or charities that are
helping enabling them. And then you tell
them that assimilation is a evil thing
in this in this charity type of
situations.
Uh what is this one um
Lutheran Family Services or something
like that. I'm not talking about
Lutherans in general. I'm talking about
specific organization that tells this
for example Afghans or uh Iraqis that
assimilating into American is not is a
bad thing, is unnecessary. Keep your
culture. We want We want you to go to
mosques and practices. You're like,
this is not normal. This cannot be um
a grassroots. It this this people have
come up with this ideas on their own. It
has to be a a very diabolical
infiltration of these specific
organizations to enable the enemy
within, empowering them, and pretty much
cut them off from any Western Christian
influence. Yeah.
And here's you know, I always say this.
You can think with me. Maybe you have a
better idea, but
you know, to find out if something's
weird or abnormal, what I like let's say
in the West, what I like to do is
compare and contrast it with behaviors
outside the West. So, we already
discussed in the West, if you're
European, well, you need to suppress
your religion and your heritage and your
culture and make room for the newcomers.
Can you think of another country or
civilization outside the West that would
ever do that? Never. There is none. And
And they're the majority. You remember
Europeans or white people are um
something like 69% of the whole world.
Okay?
And they're they're the ones who are
told, "You have to give up your land.
You have to give up your culture. You
have to suppress yourself and make room
for the minority." Because in their
eyes, they just see America and Europe.
And they they're still the majority, the
Europeans. Um so, they feel it's their
job to give in. But in the context of
the whole world, you guys are a small
dot. You're like an endangered species.
And even your own homelands, you are
being conditioned to give away and your
own civilization. It's so it's I've
never seen anything like this. It's so
mind-boggling. That's why it goes back
to it's all by design. There's no way
It's of course it's very It's a
long-term project. And it took
generations to convince people to kill
themselves the way they are, but it's
definitely by design.
I but
Raymond, I can sit here, God knows, and
I mean,
you talk there's
points ding ding ding ding in my brain
it's turning on I'm just need to
um stop and then um ask you um tell us
more about the book where can we get it
and um uh if people want to get your
articles your writings where do they
need to go everything you will say it is
already in the description of this video
and uh people can go click there but
please tell us more about that Sure and
and thanks for the opportunity Muhammad
um
so my one-stop place for everything is
my website Raymondibrahim.com
r a y m o n d i b r a h i m all my
articles are there I'm still working on
the website it's being renovated but
there's they go back that website was
created in 2004 I think so I've got over
20 years of articles last time I checked
it was over 2,000 articles that I had
written in the last two plus decades but
also there's links to my books you can
also get signed copies uh if you want to
help support my work and I'll sign a
copy and personalize it for you and then
there's links to my YouTube and whatnot
and um and this is the new book The Two
Swords of Christ which uh talks a lot
about the themes we discussed and how
Christians were able to surmount this
idea that you're a doormat and they
actually learned no that true love can
manifest itself through militancy okay
um because we're not limited to this
material world and it's all about
stopping evil in the now and protecting
the innocents and the poor um so that
book I think is going to be very I'm
hoping it it continues to open eyes like
my like its predecessors you know sword
and scimitar the sword and scimitar or
the defenders of West excellent works
thank you so much uh for what you do uh
please come back I want
I enjoyed this yeah I I think we can
talk a whole lot then about Islam itself
the origin the origins of Islam and the
laws of Islam what Muslims believe in
the in the books I'm not talking about
individual Muslims
as a general uh and I think it would be
good discussions and then uh
um maybe we do one on the defender of uh
the West the defenders of the West and
also the sword and scimitar so you're
always welcome back brother Raymond
thank you so much for your time I know
you blessed a lot of people and any any
final thoughts
No thank you very much Muhammad I'd be
very happy to join you um usually after
my first interview I decide if I'll ever
do another interview with that person
again or not and by all means you passed
with flying colors so anytime you want
just contact me and um yeah I think we
have a good chemistry and we can cover a
lot of territory Awesome awesome folks
you heard it make sure uh you go to
Raymondibrahim.com
and um
you can uh subscribe to his YouTube
channel and uh make sure all the all all
of the his X account uh I believe
Instagram account YouTube all of it is
in the description and um make sure you
support my brother and then folks thank
you so much share this everywhere
because people need to hear these things
especially Christians in your church
your pastors need to hear this